ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
ค่ะเมื่อทุเรียนมอ่ะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวัน
นี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะวันอาทิตย์นะคะเดี๋ยว
เรียนจะใช้ปากกาเขียนเขียนคูเรียมเขียนนะ
คะ
วันนี้วันอาทิตย์
วันอาทิตย์นี้อาทิตย์วันที่วันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันที่
19 ค่ะวันที่
คุยดื่มน้ำนะคะค่ะอ่ะเสือเดือนอะไรคะตัว a
เดือนธันวาคมเดือน
ธันวาคม
ปีคศอะไรคะ
คอย
ต.คออสไตส์
2021 แล้วปีพศ.ราคะปีพศ
2560  14
โอเค
วันนี้วันอาทิตย์ที่ 19 เงิน
ธันวาคม 5 ปีธกส
21 แล้วพ.ศ.ราคะ
2564 ค่ะโอเคตอนนี้เรียมยินดีกับพี่เอ๋
กี่โมงค่ะตอนนี้เวลา 6 โมง
13 นาที
วาล์ว 6 โมง 13 นาที
เราก็จะพูดพูดคุยคุยเสร็จ
18:00 น 43 น 6 โมงสี่สิบสามนาทีใช้กับ
พูดเสร็จเธอให้
คลิกที่ 20 ค่ะใช่ค่ะคลิปที่
ของเตรียมกับพี่เอ๋ใช่แล้วก็เบรคนะคะ
เสร็จแล้วนักเรียนเบรกนะคะรอปีแล้ว
ปีหน้า
อาปีนี้ปี 2021 ค่ะปีหน้าก็คือปีหน้า
2,000 บาท 22 ค่ะ
2022 เรียกว่าปีหน้านะคะปีหน้าปีหน้าปี
นี้ปีหน้าปีที่แล้ว
เห้ยวันนี้เมื่อวานนี้พรุ่งนี้
ขอ
ปีนี้ครับปีนี้ 2,000  21 ปีหน้า
ใช่ค่ะ
Hey
ครูเลี่ยมเดี๋ยววันนี้สิบเก้าแล้วก็
ตือวันตึ๊บตึ๊บตึ๊บ
บ้านเดี๋ยวค่อยหาวันวันศุกร์ค่ะวันศุกร์
คูเรียมเขียนวันศุกร์ได้ไหมขอขอขอวัน
ศุกร์ได้ค่ะวันศุกร์วันศุกร์วันศุกร์อ่ะ
วันศุกร์
วันที่ 31
ดีเดือนธันวาคม
เดือนธันวาคม 5 ให้ใช่ค่ะ
ตี้
2021 ไทยค่ะ
2021 เป็นวันวันอะไรคะเป็นวัน
สิ้นปีวันสิ้นปีวัน
ปิดเก๋า
แล้วก็จะเปลี่ยนเป็นใช่ไหมวันที่ 31
ธันวาคมเสร็จแล้วอีกวันนึงวันอะไรคะวัน
เสาร์นี้
ว่ากูใช่ค่ะเป็นวันเสาร์วันเสาร์นะคะ
วันนี้วันที่ 1 ค่ะค่า
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมกราคม
เดือน
มกราคมปีพตทคะมีผช
2565 ปีพ.ศ
2516  15 ปีคศส
ขอศ.
2522 ค่ะ
2022 คู่เรียมคะวันที่ 31 เป็นวันสิ้นปี
ใช่ค่ะสิ้นปีแล้วก็เปลี่ยนปีใหม่วันที่ 1
ใช่เรียกคุณแม่วันปีใหม่ใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะ
วันที่ 1
มกราคมเรียกว่าวันปีใหม่
ครูเรียมวันสิ้นปีแล้วก็เปลี่ยนวันปีใหม่
คนไทยทำอะไรฮะ
อ๋อคุณคนใคร
คู่ริมก่อนครูเรียมทำอะไรอ่ะเอาจริงๆครู
เรียมทำอะไร
a ปีที่แล้วเตรียมนอน
ครูเอ๋ครูเอกนอน
นอนนอนกลัวโควิชนอนดีกว่าใช่ค่ะน่า
นอนนะคะโคเรียมครูเอ๋นอนโอเคปีใหม่อารอน
นะไทยค่ะนะว่าเมื่อก่อนเมื่อก่อนงานไม่มี
โควิชอ่ะไม่มีโควิชทำอะไร
เมื่อก่อนไม่มีโควิชเตรียมก็จะปาร์ตี้เย้
Countdown  Party วันไหนคะวันที่
31 ค่ะ
วันที่ 31  31 นะคะแต่ที่ก็จะร้อง
คาราโอเกะ
[เพลง]
หรอตั้งแต่เวลากี่โมง
ร้องตั้งแต่เวลา
หือกี่โมงคะ 18:00 น
18:00 นชาย
เย็นถึงกี่โมงคะถึง
ช่วงเที่ยงคืนเที่ยงคืน
ถูกหวยถูกจะออกอา
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
[เพลง]
มาแล้วจะเหลี่ยมปี 2021 ไป 2,000 บาท 2
ไทยค่ะแล้วก็
พูดอะไรนอนเธอจะได้เลยเดี๋ยวก็นอน
คาราโอเกะหรอ
พูดอะไร
ที่คาราโอเกะไม่ได้
ที่บ้านร้องคาราโอเกะแน่ที่บ้าน
คาราโอเกะที่บ้านไม่ข้างนอกไม่ใช่ค่ะโอเค
อ่ะผู้เรียนวัดบ้าน
คาราวานที่บ้านมีที่บ้านก็จะมีคาราโอเกะ
a
ร้องคิดคู่เตรียมไปไปช่วยแล้วก็มีร้าน
คาราโอเกะ
ไม่ใช่เนื้อร้องคาราโอเกะที่บ้าน
ดีมากดีๆ
แล้วก็เที่ยงคืนก็จะพูดว่าเย้
สวัสดีปีใหม่ไทยสวัสดีปีใหม่ค่ะสวัสดีปี
ใหม่
จะพูดนะแล้วก็นอน
เที่ยงคืนแล้วใช่ไหมแป๊ปนอนนะเรียกว่าจะ
ง่วง
[เพลง]
แต่ว่าครูเรียมครูเอกของ screen เลยไหมคะ
ได้ค่ะแค่สกรีนนะ
ก่อนครูเอกทำอะไรคะ
จริงๆครูเอ๋นอน
พออ๋อตัวเองชอบมีก้อนแล้วก็ดูทีวี
เพราะว่าปีใหม่
คนคนคนมากๆนะถ่ายข้างนอกชนะที่นี่อควย
สกรีนแบบ
พระที่บ้านทวีไหมคะ
คู๋อยู่ที่คอนโดเนาะเนื้อ
ฮัลโหล 2  3  4  5  6
7  8
โหเร่ง 2  3  4  5  6  7  8 อันนี้เกิน 9
มี 8
อินเนอร์
[เพลง]
8 ชั้น
แม่กูเอ๋อยู่ชั้นที่ชั้นที่ 5
ฉันที่ขอ
ราคาอยู่คอนโดชั้นที่ 5 แล้วก็ถ้าปีใหม่ณ
วันที่ 31 น่ะ
31 แล้วก็
ออกไปข้างนอกเขามีปาร์ตี้ก็จะมีคน
คนมากคนคนคนมากๆ
บางทีโอแล้วก่อน 10,000 บาท
ของเมื่อก่อนอุ้ยหนึ่งหมื่นคน
โตครูเอ๋เวียนหัวไม่เอา
รู้เหไม่ชอบอยู่ที่นี่แล้วคนคนๆมากๆไม่
เอากูเออยู่
อยู่ที่คอนโดแล้วก็ดูทีวี
อาเภอ
ทีวีบอกโอ้ย
เซ็นทรัลเวิลด์มีคนว่ากๆคนเยอะมากมากๆดู
แล้วก็อี้
แฮปปี้สวัสดีปีใหม่แล้วคุยกัน
นอน
เรียงก็ดูดูทีวีเหมือนกันคะแต่ว่าเดี๋ยว
ก็
กดโอ้วเห็นแบบคนสวดมนต์
นะโมตัสสะภะคะวะโตมีมีบางคนก็ไปไปที่นี่
ไปไปแล้วก็ปีใหม่แต่บางคนก็ไปวัด
หัวทำไมเป็นเสียงส้ม
อ่ะอ๋อวัดสีส้มราคาได้ค่ะว่าเสียใจอ่ะณ
วัด
ไปวัดอา
รไปที่วัดที่วัดก็จะมีพระนะคะ
พระชุดสีส้มเนาะ 4 สีเหลืองเหลืองส้มส้ม
อะกูเอวาสให้
โอเคก็จะมีพระแล้วพระว่าจะ
น้ำมอเตอร์อาสาปตะวันตอนตัวตามมา 3 ผู้ตา
สวดมนต์สวดมนต์
บางคนไปวัดแล้วก็สวดมนต์ค่ะครูเรียมเรียม
เห็นที่วัดคนเยอะมากๆคนเยอะมากๆก็จะสวด
มนต์ตั้งแต่เดี๋ยวนะคะเอากี่โมงคะอาเจ้
สวดมนต์จริงๆครูเอ๋ไม่เคยไปนะแต่คิดว่า
คิดนะน่าจะตั้งแต่ 8:00 นไหม
her
แล้วแต่แล้วแต่วัดอ่ะบางทีน่าจะประมาณ
20:00 น
นะ 20:00 น
20:00 นไปจนถึง
หน้า
คืนแล้วก็เลยเที่ยงคืนสวัสดี
ปีใหม่แล้วก็เสร็จ
สวดมนต์กูโหๆ 20:00 น 21:00 น 22:00
23:00 นเที่ยงคืนกู 4 ชั่วโมง
ครูเอ๋แต่ไม่เคยไปแต่คิด
เหอะประมาณ 4 ชั่วโมง
เพราะว่าครูเอ๋เห็นเห็นที่บ้านไปวัดตั้ง
แต่
ตั้งแต่อาจจะบางคนไปตั้งแต่ 6:00 นใช่ค่ะ
18:00 นแล้วก็ไปวัด
บางคนนอนที่วัดเลย
แปลว่ากูเอ๋ไม่เคยไป
ที่บ้านเนี่ยบ้านใช่ไหมคะที่บ้านก็จะมี
พ่อ
แม่
พี่สาว
ที่ชาย
กูเอ๋น้องชายอ่ะพ่อพ่อกับเอ๋แหละคลิป
มาช่วยพี่ชายด้วยอะพี่ใส่ไปๆนะอันเนี้ย
ไม่ได้ไป
[เพลง]
เมื่อก่อนแหมบแม่ไปพี่สาวไปที่ชายไปน้อง
ชายไปผู้ชายแต่งงาน
มีภรรยาภรรยาไปมีไอ้ที่วัดนายมีลูกสาว
ลูกสาว
2 คนไปพี่สาวแต่งงาน
นี้มีลูกสาวลูกชายลูกชายสามคนเนื้อไปโห
ไปสวดมนต์ค่ากี่ใช่ไปแล้วก็สวดมนต์แล้วก็
ฟังพระ
นามรสวดมนต์ครูเอ๋โนสอ่ะ
นะ
ครูเอมไม่ดีไม่ใช่ครูเอ๋ไม่สบายบ่อยๆก็
เลยไม่ไป
คู๋วันที่ 1 ใบแต่กลางคืน
ที่นี่กลางคืนใช่ไหมคะเกล้า
การคืนไม่ไป
มือตัวเองไปวัดตอนไหนคะคู่แอบไปวัดวันที่
1 อุ้ยขอโทษค่ะ
เอกจะไป
31 ไป 31 กูเอกก็ไปวัดแต่ว่าจะไป
8:00 นเจอ
วันที่ 1 มกราคม
กูเอกก็ไปวัดอาจจะแต่ 08:00 นถึง 10:00 น
กูเอกไปวัด
กลางคืน
กลางคืนน่ะ
มืดไม่ไปอยู่บ้านนอน
ผอ.โอเคชื่อกูเอง
คะหลายๆคนไปสวดมนต์มีพระพระสวดมนต์ได้คู่
ดีมีรูปไหมกูเอก Stop วันนี้มีค่ะมี
ทะเบียนดูก่อน
คู๋
สกรีนไปก่อนนะคะคนไทยเรียกว่าสวดมนต์อะไร
คะสวดมนต์ข้ามปีขอ
ข้ามไป 202
อย่า
ห่วงขอเห็นแล้วมีไหม
นี่คนไทยจะเป็นนั่ง
อันนี้เป็นโบสถ์ใช่ไหมคะครูเรียมใช่ค่ะ
อันนี้คือโบสถ์
นี่ประกาศเสียอะไรดีนะที่วัดเนี่ยวัดจะ
วัดมีโบสถ์โบสถ์ใช่ค่ะ
มีมั้ย
นี่คือโบสถ์นะคะโบสถ์แล้วก็มีคนคนใส่ชุด
สีขาว
ใช่ค่ะสีขาวนะคะ
ว้าว
หนูคนเยอะมากๆเธอใช่นะคะแล้วก็คนก็จะขาว
แล้วก็นั่งแล้วก็สวดมนต์ x
ไม่มีอะไรครับครูเรียมเป็นเส้นเส้นเส้นโห
เส้นตรงนี้ค่ะคนไทยพูดว่าอะไรคะคนไทยพูด
ว่าสายสิญจน์สายสิญจน์นะคะสาย 4 ได้ค่ะ
มาเรียนรู้ตัว
เค้าจะลงมาแล้วก็อยู่ที่หัวใช่ไหมคะใช่
ค่ะสมมติอันนี้เป็นสายสิญจน์ที่สาย
โทรศัพท์แล้วก็
ตีหาวเล่นจะเห็นแบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่แล้วเหมือนเลยเหมือนเลยขอโทษนะคะนัก
เรียนขอโทษนะคะคนไทยไม่ได้เสียบปรับนะคะ
มีเป็นสายสิญจน์ที่นี่
สายสิญจน์หาก็จะเอาสายสิญจน์สีขาวนะสีขาว
ใช่ค่ะ
รักๆสายสิญจน์ก็จะไปที่โบสถ์ใช่ไหมเนี่ย
อย่า
ใช่มั๊ยเค้าจะโยงไก่กูทุกข์ใจมีสายสีหน้า
ที่โบสถ์ไปที่โบสถ์
รักอัสจะมีพระน้องพระก็จะมีสายสิญจน์ได้
หากพรุ่งนี้ก็คือสายสิญจน์
สายสิญจน์
ดีมาก
ครูเอกก็คิดนะเมื่อก่อนคิดไปไปเพราะครู
เอกคิดไปไม่สบายอ้าว
เอกคิดตายก็ไม่สบายโอเคนอนคิด
ต่อไปโอแข็งแรง
แต่ว่าปีนี้ปี
มีโควิช
ปีที่แล้ว
2,000 บาท 20 บาทก็มีโควิช
คนไทยไปสวดมนต์ข้ามปีได้ไหม
ไม่ได้ห่วงข้ามปีไม่ได้
สวดมนต์ข้ามปีกออนไลน์ค่ะใช่ค่ะออนไลน์
ออนไลน์หรือว่าสวดมนต์ข้ามปีที่บ้านเธอ
ใช่
รอฉะนั้นก็เปิดมีมี YouTube มี Facebook
มีเบอร์ทีวีเปิดทีวีแล้วก็สวดมนต์นาคมอร์
ตาร์ส่าพักถวัลย์แล้วก็ฟังละก็สวดอีกทีไร
บ้านนะคะใช่แล้ว
ปีนี้ครูเอกคลิปที่บ้านเหมือนกันแล้วก็
สวดมนต์หรือนอนค่ะ
สวดมนต์นิดหน่อยแล้วก็น้อ
โอเคคู๋ชอบธรรมอันนี้ค่ะช่อไปวันที่ 1
ตื่นแล้วก็มีอาหาร
หลักบาทโง่
แบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะค่ะ
ใช่ๆอันนี้ข้างหน้าบ้าน
ใกล้ๆบ้านครูเอง
มีอาหารแล้วก็ตักบาตรมีพระนักม้านั่งค่ะ
พระค่ะ
ขอโทษนะคะ
ไหว้พระก่อนสินอย่ามายุ่งมีครูเอ๋ชอบตัก
บาตรมีเฮ้ยเข้าไปตักบาตร
ในตอนนี้ไม่ได้ไป
ดู a คะเรียงเห็นทุกคน
ไม่ใส่รองเท้า
ใช่ๆเวลาปากบาทอันนี้ไม่ใช่กรุงเทพฯไม่
ใส่รองเท้า
เพราะว่า
พระพระใสไหมพระก็ไม่ใส่ผักไม่ใส่รองเท้า
ใช่พระไม่ใส่ชนะรองเท้าเมื่อ
คนนะบาทเพราะไม่ใส่ไม่ใส่รองเท้า
น่า
รำคาญนี้อยู่ตรงไหนนะอ้าวเตรียมชี้นี้
นี่ล่ะรองเท้า
ไม่ใส่ค่ะไม่มีนิสัย
Vitamin  E รองเท้าที่นี่
ไม่ใส่รองเท้าจะยืนข้างบนรองเท้าเป๋าไว้
ได้นะไม่ได้
แปลกกรุงเทพฯกรุงเทพฯอ่ะใส่
โอเคอ่า
รูปนี้ไม่ใช่กรุงเทพฯค่ะไม่ใช่ไม่ใส่รอง
เท้าโอเคค่ะอ๋อ
แต่คนไทยมีอีกนะครูเรียมบ้าอะไรคะนักบาท
บางคนเดี๋ยวกูอีกว่าได้ไหมได้ค่ะ
บางคนรึกูเอกลบนะคะ
คนไทยมีอันนี้วัดสีส้มจึงใช้
5v วะที่
วัดนะคะๆ
มาที่ 1
ณ
วัดที่ 2 เนื้อคือ
ใครว่าไม่สวย
นักเรียนบอกไม่เป็นไรที่ 3
เล็กๆแล้วกัน
วัดที่ 4 ที่ 4
วัดที่เท่าไหร่คะวัดที่ 5
แล้ววันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัดที่ 6
ที่ 6 วัดที่เท่าไหร่คะวัดที่ 7 นัดที่ 7
วัดที่เท่าไหร่คะวัดที่ 8 วัดที่ 8 แล้ว
ก็คะอันนี้ละกันวัดที่เท่าไหร่คะวัดที่ 9
นัดที่ 9 คูณเรียนเห็นนะเห็นไหมเห็นค่ะ
ง่าเห็นว่าคนไทยบางคนก็จะมีนี่ค่ะโคเรียม
ก็จะมีรถเนาะ
รถ
อาจจะเป็นรถรถตู้
รถตู้งูนี่มีคนประมาณ 9 คนถึง 10 คน
โง่
แล้วก็ขับรถไปวัดที่ 1 วัดที่ 2
วัดที่ 3
และอาจจะไป 1 สีฟ้าเนาะอะไรวัดที่ 1 วัด
ที่ 2
วัดที่สาววัดที่ 4 วัดที่ 5
มีวัดที่ 6 นัดที่ 7 แล้วก็
นัดปีที่ 8
วัดที่ 9 นี่
ไปทำอะไรคะตัว a.i. แวะ
ไปไหว้ไปไหว้พระพระพุทธรูป
เนื้อ
มีพระพุทธรูป
เนอะเออ
เว็บบ้านเหมือนนะ
เนื้อพระพุทธรุปจะประมาณ 4 และเหลืองเนาะ
อ๋อไปไหว้พระพุทธรูปนายคนไทยเรียกว่าอะไร
คะ
ไปไหว้พระ
ข้อ 9 วัด
งูไปไหว้พระ 9 วัดวันไหนคะว่าวันที่
ตั้งแต่วันที่ 1 ค่ะ
มกราคม
ไปถึง 31 มกราคมก็โอเควันที่ 1 วันที่ 2
วันที่ 3 วันที่ 4 วันที่ 5  6 โอเคอ่ะ
แรงมากๆชอบไปวันที่ 1  2  3  4  5  1 ใน
ไหว้พระ 9 วัดนะคะอ๋อถ้าเรียมไปไหว้พระ 9
วัดวันที่ 1
โชคดีที่ 1
มุกดี
เตรียมก็จะไป 9 วัดอีกหนึ่งวันที่ 1  1
วัน
1 วันนะ 1  9 วัด
ขอขอหนึ่งวันเก้าวัดใช้โม้
เรียมก็เคยแต่ก่อนเตรียมไหว้พระ 9 วัดที่
อยู่ที่บ้านเรียมออกจากบ้าน
07:00 น
หรือออกจากที่บ้าน
แล้วก็ไปวัดที่ 1 วัดที่ 2
จนครบถึงวัดที่ 9
ว่าให้พระวัดที่ 9 เสร็จกี่โมงคะเจ็บ
ที่หลับมาที่บ้านแต่ถ้า
7:00 น
7:00 นวู
กี่ชั่วโมง
AE ชั่วโมงค่ะตัว a
12 ชั่วโมงโห
สิทธิ์
212  Who เลียมโว้
ขับรถ
ข้าว
ถ่ายรูปโอเค
เป็นไปเที่ยวด้วยใช่ว่าออก
ไปเที่ยวไปกินข้าวด้วยนะคะขับรถไว้พระว่า
เช้าถ่ายรูปค่ะเดินดู
อ่า
ใส่ค่ะสบายใจใช่เราก็นั่งสมาธิด้วย
โอ้วยังเสมอคะสวดมนต์แต่หมูภาษาภะคะวะโต
ใช่ค่ะครูเรียมก็เคยไปทัวร์ 9 วัดใช่ก็
เหมือนกันค่ะไปถั่ว 9 วัด
ที่กลุ่มเทพ
เหนื่อยมาก
คู๋ไปไหว้พระ 9 วัดยังไงคะแท็กซี่ค่ะ
ไปวัดที่ 1 ก็แท็กซี่
ไปแล้วก็วัดที่ 1 เสร็จแล้วก็เดินเดินๆ
วัดที่ 2 เดินเดินปกติ 3 เดินเดินวัดที่ 4
ใกล้ๆกันวัดใกล้ๆกันแล้วเฮ้ยเหนื่อยค่า
แท็กซี่
โหโอเคตอนนี้โอเค
มี BTS
MRT
ใช่ค่ะสบายสบาย 9 วัดโอเคไว้ใช้เวลาแป๊บ
เดียวนานๆแต่ถ้าเมื่อก่อนโอ้ยเหนื่อยๆใช่
ค่ะเหนื่อยแล้วแต่เราจะ
สบายใจนะคะบายใจใช่ค่ะใจนะคะถ้าถ้าอยาก
ใช้เวลานิดหน่อยก็ไปที่วัดแล้วก็ไหว้แล้ว
ก็ไปวัดที่ 2 แล้วก็ขอให้
วาย
เราวัดกลับโอเคใช่ล่ะถ้ากินข้าวดูก็ใช้
เวลานานบางนาขอราคา
เออเพลง IS พี่เอจะไปไหว้พระ 9 วัดไหมคะ
เออ
คิดว่า 3 วัดประวัติก็โอเคคิดว่านาคิดว่า
กูเอ๋จะไป
ไปวัดหน้านัดวัดที่ 1 วัด
วัดที่ 1
น่าจะเป็นวัด
ไม่รู้เข้าได้ไหมวัดที่มีพระ
หอ
พระสีเขียวสีเกี่ยว
เรียกว่าสีเขียวมรกตเฮ้ย
วัดนะสีเขียวแบบนี้เลยโอเค
พระสีเขียว
มี
วัดพระแก้วชื่อวัดพระแก้วไม่รู้ติดไหม
เพราะว่าปีนี้
โควิชปิด
ใช่ค่ะนักเรียนรู้จักวัดพระแก้วไหมคะ
แนะเรียนคิดว่า
ที่หมักนักเรียนที่เมืองไทยรู้จักนัก
เรียนที่ยุโรปคิดว่าไม่รู้จักอ๋อเออคนไทย
ฟรี
เงิน
นักเรียนไม่ฟรีนะคะ
วัดที่ 2 วัดที่ 2
วัดที่ 2 ก็มีพระสีเขียวเหมือนกัน
งู
พระศรีคะเดี๋ยว
นะคะ
สุขุมวิท
หมอ
หนึ่ง
เป็นวัดราคาเป็นวัดเข้าวัดขอครูเอ๋หาให้
ดูไม่ถึงชื่อหวานอะไรคะคุณเอ๋วัดธรรมมงคล
เนื้อ
รักวัดธรรมมงคลเซ็กส์ธัมโมคน
โง่สุขุมวิท
101/1
กันนะคะครู a หาก่อนนักเรียนโอเคหา
มีคำมงคล
นี้
โอเคโอเคได้แล้วตัวเองแค่สกรีนให้ด้วย
หน่อยค่ะได้ๆๆครูเรียมอยากไปที่ไว้
เรียงอยากเห็นนี่ถ้า
m101 ไม่มีทับ 101 ที่ 5
สุขุมวิท 101 นะคะ
ว้าวนี่พระ
ครับพุทธรูปนะคะนักเรียนพระพุทธรูปสีสี
เขียวสีเขียวสี
เขียว
คู๋ชอบงู
จะไปไหว้พระใกล้อยู่ในบ้านหมูเออแล้วก็
เอาพวกวัดวัดศรี 3 นี่
วัด
อ๋อ
วัดนี้ค่ะครูเรียมวันนี้เล่งเนยยี่มีพระ
พุทธรูป
123 ฮือฮือ
เป็นวัดคนจีน
ใช่ค่ะคนตีนครูเอกก็จะไปอุ้ยขอโทษนะคะ 3
วัดนะคะ 3 วัด
วัดวัดที่ 3
แล้วจะมีพระพุทธรูป
นี้สีเหลืองทองใช่ใช่ค่ะมี
พระพุทธรูป
3 องค์สห 3 องค์
ครูอาจาร
วัตรงาน
มี
เองนานไปได้ไหมไม่รู้
ใจได้ไหมอุ่มไอคอน
ไม่เป็นไรดูทีวีแล้วก็นะโมตัสสะสวดมนต์
ข้ามปีเธอโอเคโอเคนะคะโอเคคลิปนี้
หมดแม้ว่าจะหมดเวลาไหม
[เพลง]
ใช่ค่ะนี่เน็ตเวลาแล้ว
เป็นคลิปที่ 20  20 หน้าแรกครูเรียมกับ
ครูเอ๋ไม่รู้เนาะปีหน้าบางทีเจอกันนะคะ
ได้ค่ะบุรีรัมย์ขอบคุณนะคะขอบคุณมากนะคะ
พี่คุณค่ะขอบคุณนักเรียนนะคะขอบคุณมากๆนะ
คะนักเรียน
สวัสดีปีใหม่สวัสดีปีใหม่ค่ะค่ะยิ่งไป
แล้วอ่ะ